من اقراط الثريا التي ارتدتها احلام وقميص
محمد رمضان المثير للجدل الى جحيم دوجا
وتاثير باربي غرائب الموضه عروض مبهره
وارقام قياسيه في
[موسيقى]
2023 ابهرت مغنيه الرابعه الامريكيه دوجا
المشاهدين خلال عرض لدار ازياء سكيا
باريلي في 2023 باطلاله مثيره غطى فيها
اللون الاحمر جسدها بالكامل ورصع ب 30,000
قطعه كريستال ووصفت فنانه المكياج
الاطلاله بجحيم دوجا بينما اطلت كندل جينر
ونعومي كامبل واخريات بازياء مزينه برؤوس
حيوانات مزيفه مذهله في واقعيتها ومستوحا
من جحيم
دانت كما قلبت علامه الازياء فيكتور اند
رولف الموضه راسا على عقب حرفيا في عرض
وصف بالمجنون لمجموعتها لربيع وصيف 2003
وكان هناك الكثير من الاطلالات الخلاقه
والخارجه عن المالوف في حفل متالا تكريما
للمصمم الراحل كار لاجرفيلد وقطته
الشهيره اكثر من اول
احبك بس
[موسيقى]
ماقول عربيا اطلت المطربه الاماراتيه
احلام في ليلتها الماسيه في موسم الرياض
الماضي مرتديه اقراط ضخمه وصفت بالثريا
نالت نصيبا وافرا من تع قا المتفاعلين مع
الحفل وخلال احدى حفلاته في جده نال
الفنان المصري احمد سعد نصيبه من التفاعل
والجدل ايضا بسبب اطلالته كما اثارت
اطلاله شقيقه الفنان عمر سعد جدلا مشابها
وامتد جدل اطلالات الفنانين المصريين في
2023 للفنان محمد رمضان الذي ظهر بقميص
اعتبر خارجا عن المالوف في عيد
[موسيقى]
ميلاده
ومن غرائب الموضه الى العروض الغنائيه
التي وصفت بالمبه في عام 2023 ومنها عرض
بيونسيه في دبي وكان اول عرض مباشر للنجمه
الامريكيه منذ العام
2018 وشاركت في عرض بيونسيه فرقه مياس
اللبنانيه التي ابهرت في
2023 جمهور برنامج المواهب الشهير امريكا
كاتلان مجددا بتقديمها عرضها المصور الاول
حره وكانت رهانا محط انظار ملايين
المشاهدين في امريكا خلال تقديمها عرض
استراحه ما بين شوطي نهائي السوبر بول
الذي نظمته رابطه كره القدم الامريكيه في
203 ايضا واعتبر عرضها تكثيفا مبهرا
لمسيرتها الفنيه على مدى 17
عاما وقامت تيلور سويفت التي اختارتها
مجله تايم شخصيه العام بجوله فنيه تجاوزت
عائداتها لاول مره في تاريخ العروض
الغنائيه عتبه المليار دولار من خلال 60
حفله بين مارس ونوفمبر
2023 وحقق فيلم باربي ايرادات تجاوزت
المليار دولار عالميا خلال ثلاثه اسابيع
وذلك وفقا لتقديرات رسميه ايرادات وصفت
بالمذله والقياسيه بينما اجتاح ما بات
يعرف بتاثير باربي منصات التواصل عالميا
كما اعلن المخرج المصري بيتر ميمي ان فيلم
بيت الروبي من بطوله كريم عبد العزيز
وكريم محمود عبد العزيز اصبح رسميا الاعلى
تحقيقا للاراده من شباك التذاكر في تاريخ
السينما المصريه متفوقا بذلك على فيلم
كيرا والجن المخرج ذاته ومن بطوله احمد عز
وكريم عبد
العزيز وعلى سيره الارقام القياسيه دخلت
المطربه اللبنانيه نجوى كرم في 20 موسوعه
جينس للارقام القياسيه ما اثر نوعا من
الجدل على منصات التواصل فالرقم الذي
ادخلها الموسوعه لا علاقه له باي انجاز
موسيقي وانما باطول رداء في العالم
ه